- It's Akilah and I am
with Comedy Central
at South by Southwest trying
to talk to some people
about what South By is about.
How's the festival treating you?
- Crazy.
I got shot.
- You know Austin's an
amazing comedy town.
- What's your favorite thing
about South by Southwest?
- You got people
playing the guitar,
you can smell the patchouli.
You will just get in the zone.
- So when you say patchouli,
are you talking about weed?
- Yeah, there's a lot of it.
- All right, that was a
cool way of saying it.
- Is everything bigger in Texas?
- My dreams are bigger.
This wifi's fast and
my bumble is loading.
- Black or pinto beans.
- Pinto.
- Racist.
- They're beans of color,
they're not like fava beans.
- Do people tell you all
the time that you look like
if Martin Luther King's
dream was realized.
- One day that black
people and white people
and Mexican people can
come together in Austin
and be weird.
- [Akilah] Do you
remember the Alamo?
- Is that when pie
has ice cream on it?
- It was one of
the first gay bars.
A lot of people don't know that.
- Tindr is basically my Alamo.
- Your Alamo.
It's my Waterloo.
- It's my Normandy.
- Thank you, I really
messed that up.
I'm so sorry.
- It was cute.